qui était Candida à la mairie,
est totalement contre.
C'est une situation plutôt rare.
- Bon matin! Bon matin!
- Balarama Holness et
Marc-Antoine Desjardins du parti
unifié Mouvement Montréal
souhaitent une consultation
publique pour déterminer
si les Montréalais désirent
un référendum sur la langue.
BALARAMA HOLNESS,
candidat à la mairie de Montréal
- Dans cette consultation
publique-là, on va avoir
le pouls de la ville pour
savoir si la ville de Montréal
veut un référendum sur la langue
pour déterminer la langue
officielle ou les langues
officielles de Montréal.
- Monsieur Holness a indiqué que
c'est l'Office de consultation
publique de Montréal qui
serait responsable de mener
à bien cette consultation.
Le chef de Mouvement Montréal
a cependant été incapable
de dire comment il modifierait
la Charte de la ville pour
changer son statut linguistique.
Seul le gouvernement du Québec
peut le faire. Balarama Holness
a plusieurs fois répété
qu'il souhaitait voir Montréal
comme ville bilingue.
Un souhait que ne partage pas
le numéro deux du parti.
MARC-ANTOINE DESJARDINS,
candidat à la mairie Outremont,
- On va avoir les gens
qui vont vouloir rendre
Montréal peut-être bilingue;
bonne chance! Et on va avoir
les gens qui vont vouloir garder
Montréal française, normalement.
Bien là, ils vont m'avoir
dans leur camp.
- La réaction des deux
principaux candidats à la mairie
n'a pas tardé.
VALÉRIE PLANTE, candidate
à la mairie de Montréal
- Pour moi, il y a pas de raison
de remettre en question
le statut francophone
de la ville à Montréal,
qui fait partie de la Charte.
DENIS CODERRE,
candidat à la mairie de Montréal
- Je m'objecte complètement
à un référendum sur
cette question-là. Je ne pense
pas que c'est une bonne idée.
- Les deux dirigeants de
Mouvement Montréal disent
pouvoir travailler ensemble,
malgré leur position différente
sur la langue.